[Music]
okay 2022
there's no way it's not better than 2021
right
right hi what's up mkbhd here we made it
to 2022 all right so there was plenty of
tech happening still in the past year in
2021 we had some truly great new
computers we had plenty of interesting
and unique smartphones the mirrorless
camera world took a step up there were a
bunch of good evs and a bunch of even
better eevee promises the ps5 is a whole
year old and still impossible to get but
now it's time to look forward this is a
little tradition i've started sort of
the beginning of each new year where i
look forward at the next year in tech
actually usually there's a bit of a
frenzy right at the beginning of the
year in the form of ces in las vegas
every january this is actually the first
year in like a decade that i'm not going
to ces as fun as it probably still could
be it doesn't seem like the most
responsible thing to go do for me right
now but nevertheless i just looked at
the calendar there's a lot of new fun
tech to look forward to for 2022. so i'm
just gonna start off at the top of my
list which is apple silicon so the mac
transition to apple silicon started in
june 2020. it was announced on stage at
wwdc and they said on stage that this
transition would take two years that
announcement
was a year and a half ago so
we got to be finishing it up now right
so we have an apple silicon macbook air
macbook pro baseline imac
next up or last up would be a bigger
imac or imac pro
and the tower the mac pro so the imac
pro i think probably has the simplest
formula right all they really have to do
is put the new m1 pro or m1 max chip in
there and then give the larger display
with the squared off design kind of like
the pro display xdr you probably also
give it black bezels and uh high refresh
rate and call it a day i mean a couple
extra ports and mag safe and keeping the
sd card slot and the headphone jack
would also be great that's your new imac
we've seen lots of mock-ups and
renderings of what something like this
could look like
some of them have a notch some of them
don't i mean on a display that big you
probably don't need to do a notch cut
out but i could totally see them doing
it either way i think that imac pro will
be great for a lot of people and i think
it'll be very tempting for me but i
won't be switching to it because i'm
waiting for the tower so the developing
background information seems to be
pointing toward a pretty beastly apple
silicon mac pro finally coming this year
it would actually be smaller than the
current intel mac pro tower since apple
silicon is so efficient but it would
also be for sure the new largest chip
they've ever made we're looking at up to
a 40 core cpu and 128 core gpu really
the main reason i'm so excited for these
machines is we've seen what is so
impressive about apple silicon in the
past which is that they're so powerful
and so efficient compared to these intel
and amd chips but that's because they're
in laptops and things that are battery
powered and they have to be efficient
but for the imac and the mac pro
of course you still want to be
relatively efficient so people plugging
them into their setups aren't getting
higher electricity bills but now you're
working with way more wattage way larger
thermal envelopes it's like the best
most unlocked version of apple silicon
possible
and i just can't wait to see how they
perform
i'm ready this is the definition of tech
i am ready for
please drop one in my setup right now
there's also rumors of a new slightly
smaller high refresh rate like pro
display too to go alongside it to match
may or may not happen alongside but i
think that'll be pretty cool too but i
think we just keep forgetting that
machines like this are not meant to be
bought and used by regular people for
regular everyday computing things like i
don't have a mac pro at home
i just you get a regular computer you
get a laptop you get a little even a
bass line all in one totally fine
but when i use that huge mac pro at my
desk it's a workhorse it's it's been a
rock it's been churning through things
but even now that thing kind of feels
slow in some single threaded tasks
compared to
like even the m1 macbook air so
very excited to see what they do uh all
that being said this is all apple stuff
and i've gotten a lot of the information
of like what i really
trust and hope to see from mark german
he's kind of the only one i trust with
this stuff uh so also from his
newsletter iphone 14.
so this could be an interesting one one
thing that always comes to mind with the
iphone is okay new year new iphone what
are they gonna
phase out this time what are they gonna
try to get rid of does the lightning
port have another year of life left here
maybe i heard they might be also trying
to get rid of the physical sim card in
the sim card tray that wouldn't shock me
at all but there are a couple of things
i'm specifically looking forward to in
the next iphone because number one they
would make it a better phone but number
two because
the uh the iphone effect sort of tends
to have the rest of the industry follow
and i think it would be a good thing to
follow so for one they could potentially
be adding the pro motion display across
the whole lineup across all the new
iphone 14s even an iphone 14 mini if
they do another mini and this would be
really nice to see if these were all
presumably ltpo displays all the way
across the board too
for battery life of course so it's a
subtle thing but ltpo displays allow you
to ramp up not just to a higher fresh
rate of 120 hertz but at different
refresh rates underneath that in between
depending on what's going on on the
screen all that to save your battery
life in the last video i gave my
impressions of the galaxy s21 fan
edition and i accidentally put ltpo in
my graphic that's actually incorrect
that's my bad it's a standard regular
120 hertz ammo led so i pinned a comment
to correct that but really you only find
ltpo or this variable refresh rate on
the highest end phones so the fold
threes of the world the galaxy s21
ultras
the apple find x3 pros the cheapest
phone out right now offering ltpo is the
800
oneplus 9 pro so if we do see apple
bring that down across the entire iphone
14 lineup to the cheapest iphone iphone
14 mini if it's what it ends up being
that would be very impressive and
something that i hope the others copy
too it's funny how we go from seeing
apple so far behind on high refresh rate
to maybe leading the next wave of it but
also iphone 14 cameras this could this
could be the first year in a long time
that we see the iphone megapixel bump
here's a chart from my reviewing every
iphone ever video of megapixel counts of
the iphone's cameras every single iphone
since 2015 has had a 12 megapixel sensor
and that's not a bad thing they've got
this really dialed over the years and
low light performance with these large
pixel sizes is great the rumor this year
is we may see finally a 48 megapixel
iphone camera
i love this of course but the more i've
thought about it the more i feel like
this may potentially be
handled in a kind of weird apple way see
apple's been sticking to the 12
megapixel sensors for so long and
they've got lots of good reasons it's
high enough resolution to look really
great anywhere you might send it in a
text message social media whatever and
if you blow it up and you want to print
one then it'll look okay so why would
they switch
well presumably this could be a year
where apple really focuses on having a
pro camera and a pro camera offers you
the ability to do much more with your
photos so you can have you can have that
super high resolution pro mode of course
it will typically just be binning
everything to 12 megapixels anyway for
normal people and normal shots but that
pro mode would be sweet and on top of
that you know what 48 megapixels unlocks
for you
8k video
so if they're getting really serious
about pro video they can of course join
the club of smartphones being able to
shoot an 8k but now imagine
how much storage space
8k
prores video on the iphone would take up
i mean we already have an absurd amount
if you've ever shot 4k prores on the
iphone it's a lot and uh you can't even
shoot 4k pro res on the baseline 128 gig
pro iphone so i'd imagine they would
have some other restriction to shoot 8k
prores maybe you'd have to have the one
terabyte iphone i don't know but the
most fascinating iphone 14 rumor that's
gaining steam is probably that they'll
be moving to a hole punch camera on the
front and moving the rest of the face id
system underneath the display huh now to
me
that's actually that actually seems to
work perfectly it's really clever it
almost makes you wonder why they didn't
do it earlier because we know the
cameras that exist underneath displays
today
you know they've been okay but they're
really not the best quality or
resolution as far as actual images you
can get out of them now the face id
sensor is really just working with
projecting a bunch of infrared dots so
they don't have to have this super high
clarity or resolution to work just as
well so in theory yeah you can already
just move those right underneath the
display glass with today's tech they'll
keep working fine and for the pristine
actual selfie image quality you give
that little hole punch cut out and still
have a normal selfie camera so that'll
be cool but let's get out of apple camp
galaxy s22 is right around the corner
following up on their winning the
smartphone of the year award with the
galaxy s21 ultra and i see that this
design change that's pretty heavily
rumored is probably happening
i don't hate it i don't love it but i
don't hate it maybe i like it more when
i hold it i think phones tend to always
look better in person than they do in
the renders but pretty much everything
that was already really good about s21
ultra is rumored to be upgraded in this
phone again it's a classic samsung way
better chipset better specs better
display
uh better cameras 8k 60fps video is
slated so they can already do 8k 24 but
30 would be cool and 60 would take a lot
of space but it'd be cool too so that's
the typical samsung through all the
hardware added way and then there's also
the possibility of including an s pen
this one not so sure about maybe it is
included with support or maybe there's
an s22 note edition or something like
that so we haven't seen a galaxy note in
at least a year but maybe this is their
way of bringing it back the s pen lives
on as long as that happens so that'd be
pretty cool i just really hope they
don't curve the display over the edges
again i've seen a bunch of different
mock-ups and little 3d renders and
leaked posts and the one thing a lot of
them have in common is a really curved
display now i like that it's a boxier
design kind of like the note always was
and i like the flat top and bottom but
samsung really got it right by reducing
the curve in the s21 ultra display and
it would be a weird move to go back on
that to a huge curve again we do now
have official oneplus 10 pro
uh design and specs so by the time
you're seeing this we've got the
official numbers and photos from oneplus
this is sort of following up on going
for redemption for the lackluster year
of the oneplus 9 series i don't hate
this design it clearly was inspired a
lot by what samsung just did with their
cameras but it's sort of their own take
on it but it's definitely different i'm
okay with it i'm sure you'll all have
your own thoughts on this in the
comments section below but i'm i'm okay
with this but the spec sheet is
absolutely nuts it's all maxed out specs
i'll just toss it over here or something
so you can see it uh i think the most
impressive part though is 80 watt wired
charging and they're calling it super vu
charging instead of what they used to
call one plus fast charging which is
dash charging so this is
yet another step in the uh operation of
the one successful brand under that
umbrella in north america which is one
plus but that's enough phones i got one
more thing that i'm really excited and
ready for in 2022 which is evs electric
vehicles and specifically
this sort of trio of trucks so that
would be the rivien
the f-150 lightning and the cyber truck
now rivien has started shipping their
r1t pickup truck which i literally loved
honestly on my list of evs i've ever
driven
it's got to be top five i mean there's
plaid model s
tycan e-tron
i'm putting pulsar in there but then
this has definitely got to be in there
in no particular order so they're
officially delivering them we should
start seeing them more and more on the
streets this year
also alongside the r1s which is
essentially on the same platform but
it's the suv version it's even lower
volume than the pickup truck but that's
also anticipated for 2022 and then i
also got my first look at the f-150
lightning last year and just today i saw
a headline that they're planning to
double their production so clearly
they're seeing a lot of interest and
that's all assuming no delays so they're
saying something like spring 2022 that's
assuming assuming no delays and then the
tesla cyber truck is the most delayed so
far out of all these three last we heard
elon tweeted that it would be coming out
late 2022 barring unforeseen delays but
then again also last week tesla removed
the 2022 estimate from their website so
hopefully not delayed maybe also
technically the uh the electric hummer
that we just looked at this this past
year is also coming out so that's four
uh i think this would be really fun if
we did a new
thousand mile road trip comparing gas
versus electric but this time do with
trucks i mean we can get a regular f-150
but we can also do these electric trucks
and do it while towing something so we
can learn something again from this road
trip i think it'll be pretty fun the
first one
was a lot of fun and we learned a lot so
maybe leave a thumbs up if you want to
see that in 2022. actually it might be
kind of hard to do all that while towing
stuff because then you still need to
like back into a charger but then that's
tough with a trailer maybe we'll just do
this with a bunch of weight in the bed i
think bottom line is it'll be it'll be
pretty next level
next level like our current channel
sponsor cash app cash app is the easiest
way to spend send and save your money we
already know it's great for sending your
friends some money or having them pay
you back for something but also you can
buy bitcoin and save money and invest on
cash app that's probably right in line
with your new year's resolutions too so
join cash app you can use code marquez
to get 15 bucks dropped into your
account right away and 10 will go to
girls who code so there's a bunch of
other little small things i'm interested
in there's maybe a quest three coming
this year from meta since they've it's
still weird saying that i'm so used to
saying oculus quest but a meta quest
three considering how important the
metaverse is to them
maybe if we get a pixel 7 we also get a
pixel watch alongside that
that's probably not happening
but generally a lot of really cool stuff
coming for 2022 let me know in the
comment section below what you're most
interested in seeing this year i
definitely want to cover as much of it
as i can but i want to get a sense of
what you guys want to see too so that's
been it thanks for watching welcome to
the new year
catch you guys the next one peace